things have not gone very well for this
elderly gentleman pretending to be the
president of the united states ted cruz
summed it up nicely in a tweet
let's pull that up over there the state
of the union under president biden can
be summed up in one word crisis
inflation crisis border crisis
afghanistan crisis covid crisis supply
chain crisis ukraine crisis
crime crisis we're just going to kind of
dive into each one of those issues and
let's let's see we're going to present
you with some numbers and
you decide whether things are going well
or not first off we've got some data
from real clear politics on biden's
approval ratings or i guess i should say
disapproval rating
which is up
13.8 points since he took office so as
you can see what you're looking at there
the red line that's constantly going up
that's disapproval so that's up about 14
points
and the approval which is the black line
you if you're the president you want
that one to go up that that's the one
that's going down and you can see
there's sort of a direct correlation
between the up and the down right there
that people are just not happy with this
guy now why would it be
that people are not happy uh with this
joe biden fellow well first let's talk
about the economy and inflation we've
got some data here from the u.s
inflation calculator the annual
inflation rate for the united states is
7.5
for the 12 months
ended in january 22 2022 the highest
since february 1982 and after rising
seven percent previously in 2021
according to u.s labor department data
published on february 10th so we all
know that our are the dollars that we've
got in our wallet
or what you've got in your paypal
account or your stripe account that
you're trading and going back and forth
on on zell or whatever payment thing you
use to to pay people for goods and
services we just know that that money is
not worth as much and you are now
getting less for it look at the price of
beef go to the supermarket
carton eggs milk etc etc uh we've got
some info here from powder and bulk
solids this is a manufacturing
publication talking about what's going
on with the supply chain and actually
the nuts and bolts of the economy
america's manufacturing industry shed
578 000 jobs in 2020 according to
federal data a report published this
year by deloitte and the manufacturing
institute forecasts that
2.1 million manufacturing positions
could be unfilled in the u.s by 2030.
shipping information company fredos told
reuters this august that the price to
ship 140 container from china to the
east coast climbed more than 20 000 an
increase of more than 500 percent from
the previous year this is real this is
real stuff you all know it like everyone
knows it i can read you the numbers but
just think in your own life when you're
going to the store and you're buying
food are you paying more money or less
or is it the same
pretty much worse for everybody so okay
so that's one thing we know that the
economy is just struggling and you
almost don't need me to explain it to
you you just know it well then cruz
talked about the border stuff and
immigration uh so first let's start with
some video of our southern border we
don't talk about the border anymore for
some reason when that orange man was
president we were always talking about
the border and there was going to be a
wall and there was racists and the whole
freaking thing here's our border in
september of 21 this is del rio texas
beneath this border bridge in del rio
texas a group of migrants grows by the
hour the men women and children mostly
from haiti tonight they number nearly 15
thousand tripling in size since
wednesday all waiting in near 100 degree
heat washing clothes in the rio grande
and sleeping outside for a chance to
claim asylum we need the administration
secretary myorch is the vice president
and the president to call this what it
is this is a crisis
with staff unable to keep up with
processing state lawmakers are calling
on washington for help now the numbers
believe it or not
have gotten significantly worse i
suspect that you will believe it we've
got some data here from u.s customs and
border protection
the this is southwest land border
encounters over a year okay so in 2020
we had about 458 000 encounters now this
means you know someone's coming across
illegally they got caught they're
interrogated etcetera etcetera this
isn't exactly uh what they do with those
people at the time but in 2020
uh we had 458 000 of these interactions
that's when the orange man was president
in 2021 uh we had 1.734
million now i don't have my calculator
here uh but you guys can confirm this
for me uh that's significantly more it's
about 1.3 uh million more than uh the
year before and then and of course joe
biden was president in 2021 and then
just in these last few months the last
four months roughly october 2021 to
january 2022 beginning of this year
we've had 672
000 of these encounters now how many of
these people are here how many of these
people were arrested or sent back how
many of them have children that are now
here all the we don't really know but we
all kind of know something ain't right
then of course there was afghanistan
kabul airport this morning is back up
and running evacuation flights for u.s
embassy personnel and contractors in
full swing
flights were stopped yesterday when tens
of thousands of afghans stormed onto the
runways desperate to leave clinging onto
aircraft trying not to be left behind as
the americans pull out
u.s troops found themselves overwhelmed
as they tried to clear the airport
firing warning shots the pentagon says
american troops killed two armed afghans
but some afghans were able to get out on
one flight so full it may have set a
record for the number of people who can
fit onto an american c-17
afghans are running from the taliban now
in full control setting up checkpoints
with the very weapons american taxpayers
bought for the afghan army which
collapsed instead of fighting after the
u.s pulled out of bases and left them
without air support
now doesn't that all feel like a
lifetime ago and it's sort of like well
why should we care anymore we're gone
um but you know as we talk now about
what's going on with russia and ukraine
it's like what do people around the
world think the united states is all
about what do we do for our allies and
the people on the ground who are the
translators who are helping us fight the
taliban and everything else as they
reported right there the amount of
weapons we literally left hundreds of
millions of dollars of weapons and tanks
and helicopters
and munitions and all of these things
that are now in the hands of the people
that we were supposedly fighting
and the people that we betrayed on the
ground and again i'm not even saying we
were supposed to be there in the first
place and of course we had to wrap it up
but we we did it horrifically absolutely
horrifically and of course as you
remember we've got some info from
reuters here i mean this was the sort of
worst of it as if those images of
afghans falling off the plane wasn't bad
enough uh marines from the second
battalion first marines regiment were on
duty outside of the kabul airport on
august 26 when a suicide bomber
detonated explosives killing at least 13
u.s service members and scores of
afghanistan of afghanis um you know it's
kind of interesting because we don't
know their names right mainstream media
didn't show you their names these 13
people who signed up to protect the
united states who then died
due to a suicide bomber in a
horrifically botched escape from a
country that we're not totally sure why
we were in in the first place after you
see what happened in afghanistan
only you know roughly eight months ago
and the disaster there it's like do you
think that this administration led by
this joe biden who's going to give the
speech tonight do you think that that
these people are trustworthy or know
what they're doing or anything else i
wonder what our allies think i've got a
quote here from khn news
this is uh they are talking about
tuesday the last tuesday of trump's
presidency the death toll of covid
reached 400 000 people
a once unthinkable number so that was
the cumulative amount of people who had
died of kobit under donald trump 400 000
people as uh he hit the last day of his
presidency uh now we've got some info
here uh from the white house in february
of 2022
today our nation marks another tragic
milestone
900 000 american lives have been lost to
covid19 what this means
okay is that 400 000 people
died under that scary orange man donald
trump from covid and 500 000 have died
in the year under joe biden joe biden
ran
saying that he was going to end kovid
right uh here's some video of joe biden
back in october 2020 right before the
election 220
000 americans dead if you hear nothing
else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
okay as always he muddled what he was
saying there but in essence at that
point there were 220 000 deaths there's
now been 500 000 under joe biden so by
his own words as muddled as they may be
i'm pretty sure he's saying that he
should step down